it's time for screen junkies movie
fights what in the world its movie
fights what's going on everybody
hashtag movie fights live it is all
happening we are alive we are not
pre-recorded check it and I gotta give a
shout-out to hashtag holla nation
Perceval is in the house and percival is
a nice little owl and we've got a nice
little movie fights for you let's go
ahead and meet our combatants first up
Oh
this gentleman is becoming a force to be
reckoned with right here on movie fights
from harm Piper RPG and all over the
internet and he's quite a little
shutterbug to try and Ryan Cameron Rice
Cameron what's up buddy hey how's it
going now good to see you man I'm
excited to be here don't I'm not sick I
don't have the flu people left and right
I'm so glad you are hale and hearty and
here to fight
second up he is the host of the meaning
of podcast
he's been here showed his skills on the
movie fights many a time welcome back to
the party ace Cabrera hey thanks for
having me man
oh great having you and yeah are you
feeling it are you ready to do battle
I'm feeling it all right win you know
what you've got a one in three chance
today and also wearing a Batman shirt so
we got ace Billy
Cameron you get the memo no no that
would have been fun if the far three
fighters randomly showed up in Batman
here Billy biz Patterson William
business how are you good sir usually
producing or SJ newsing but today you're
fighting here get well soon
Edie I'll try to win this one for you
buddy
yeah definitely super prepared for for
today's fight as always but you know
what last two times I fought I did lose
but I lost to two former movie fights
champion I lost a Dan and I lost a
cucumber so maybe today today is my day
some call that a badge of honor some
call that an excuse I'm just kidding
holy smokes it's great to have you
across the table best of luck to you
surfing and deciding the fights will be
myself and the folks on the Dan cam dan
Merle will be weighing in with his
opinions and giving us the factuality
Dan what's going on my friend fighting I
had a hard fight last week oh you did
that was a grueling fight right now like
he pushed you on every question but you
emerged retaining the title belt
emerging the champion I said I had two
title fights in three days how I had
this one on Thursday and I had a row
down one on Saturday well the crazy
Schmo down in New York said well I don't
hasn't aired yet so I won't say what
happened but the two big fights in three
days that's a lot of a lot of fight and
hell man I'm glad I'm glad you are I'm
glad you're still here
I'm here held a tail ready to check some
facts hell yeah thank you sir and the
voice of the people the one and only
Danielle radford Danielle would you
please favor them with what you'll be
doing yes so I am the voice the people I
am yo we will be having polls that go up
for every round they go up after the
initial arguments have begun because
they want these to be based on the
arguments you can also change them your
vote if something happens and someone
sways you more over to their side if you
are looking for instructions on how to
use the YouTube polls they should be
down in the description below there are
other really fun polls that happen on
Twitter and people start their own those
are great but the only one that counts
is this and that poll is our tiebreaker
so in the case that these two gentlemen
cannot agree and then we the people
shall decide if it winds up being a
three-way tie then I get my own vote
also I will be checking on movie fights
live the hashtag on Twitter please join
in there you guys always have the best
ideas theories alternate answers great
explanations great jokes so go and do
and get active on the movie fights live
hashtag because I'm a shout you out on
the show oh hell yeah it's always fun
when like you say one of the answers and
I'm like how come none of y'all thought
of that
you know also we love when you send us
really stupid memes please yes please
once again how the show works the first
person to four points will walk out of
here the winner there are three regular
round questions than the top two scores
after those three rounds head over to
the speed round and the speed round to
anybody's game someone can be up three
oh and the other player can make a
furious comeback in the speed round I
don't think there's any more to say
y'all ready for this mhmmm jte please
drop that sick ass package
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Thor all right here we go
you know what ace and Billy's shirts are
apropos with this first question Ben
Affleck he's out batfleck bye-bye flying
the coop so we asked who should play
Bruce Wayne / Batman in 2020 ones the
Batman oh man that's gonna be big news
when it drops maybe we have a precursor
to that right here first up Cameron
going with an answer here that uh he was
he was bounded about before not that
long ago when there was talk of that
Affleck might not be taking the role
back that there might be might be its
own separate universe all that other
stuff I am going with Oscar Isaacs an
actor who's shown to be very versatile
he's got that dark brooding quality to
him but there's a list of films where
he's shown many different sides and like
the Batman has many different sides as
well I think by if we look at movies
like drive or ex machina you can see the
determined broken-down person which
we've seen within Bruce Wayne if we look
at someone like Poe Dameron we see a
kind of character that could take on and
Robins and night wings and be a valiant
leader as he is with Finn in that movie
and if we look at something like inside
Llewellyn Davis you might see a broken
sad brooding man which we've often seen
Batman be as well I think Oscar Isaacs
has shown all the qualities what it
would take to be a different kind of
Batman for multiple multiple Batman
films okay the many sides of Oscar Isaac
ace yes so when thinking about this
question I was thinking about who's an
up-and-coming rising action star who can
deliver the physicality that we know
that Batman has I went with that and
then I went with someone who can carry
this franchise to the future they want a
young Batman for this 2021 Batman so I
went with a young Bruce Wayne who I feel
that can embody the physicality of
Batman and that is Dylan O'Brien most
people know him from The Maze Runner
movies if you've seen American assassin
as well
that this guy is a bonafide action star
he can do the martial arts he can do his
own stunts
he even almost got killed doing a stunt
with the Maze Runner movies that's how
committed he is as an actor he can carry
the franchise to the future and I think
he can give a lot as far his is Bruce
Wayne persona as well thank you ace
Billy biz okay so we want to take Batman
younger I think we all agree um but one
thing I feel like Batman has been
missing since the days Michael Keaton I
want my Batman a Batman who I can look
at in and see a little bit of crazy in
there because I think Batman is the best
when you understand that he is in some
ways just one hair away from the line of
crossing over to the other side and I
think the guy that could do both now
follow me on this okay because I think
it's gonna be a little strange but
follow me on this I think the guy that
you want to do this is Zachary Quinto
now I know that look at that face now
first of all when I think of what Batman
looks like and I see a photo like that
that makes me think of great Kapoor yo
Scott Snyder that Batman that court of
owls that little bit younger Batman but
we've seen from Zachary Quinto not only
can he carry a franchise like he has
with Star Trek and be a character that
we can get behind but also we've seen
how with a character like Sylar in
heroes where he can be a little bit you
don't really know where he falls there
were there were times on that show where
he was he was just like what are you
doing and then there were other times
where you're like I get where you're
coming for him I get that pain I
understand he can play all of that crazy
and I think when we're talking about a
young Batman that's one thing that we
haven't really delved into is this could
be a Batman that needs to find those
limits of what makes him a hero
versus just another one of the crazy
people in Gotham and I think the person
that could nail that is mr kwinto a
beefed-up mr. Quentin Quentin EP quince
okay
quinta on that no let's fight it out let
me start out by saying this I bel ofin
in the room yeah okay you guys pick two
40 year olds to point Batman when they
want a younger Batman we already had the
ben affleck batman we already have the
old grizzled batman Oscar Isaac is
currently 39 Zachary Quinto is beautiful
man what are your old men beautiful man
let's fountain of youth is Zachary
Quinto sippin always ready to go mister
me the elephant in the room would be you
picked a very young looking man they're
looking for they are looking for a yo
Batman but I want them to make a good
movie I'm not saying this actor wouldn't
do a good job he probably would do a
very good job but I think also you guys
pick two actors who at this point have
shown they're very good at the brood but
there's more sites to Batman than that
my favorite Batman personally is the
animated series Batman what I love about
that Batman is his Bruce Wayne when he's
out in public is kind of aloof kind of
like he's a good like social kind of guy
but at the same time is a little like
like doesn't seem to quite get it I
think the last couple Batman's we've
seen a lot of broody dark Batman as far
as it can do dark and broody but I think
with Poe Dameron Oscar Isaac can also be
that kind of fun aloof Bruce Wayne you
could see this guy out in public dating
models and people who believable he
would be like this guy's not Batman I
think even if you just look at Oscar
Isaac in Drive and then who he is as PO
Dameron are two completely different
types of characters on top of the fact
that this means this Batman could also
be matches Malone you mean have a Batman
who goes in disguise as a different
looking guy
Zachary Quinto is always gonna look like
exactly I own I'm with you I'm actually
kind of with you as far as I can see
Oscar Isaac is plain of Bruce white I do
not see him putting any kind of Batman
whatsoever ex-market the guy is five
foot six tiny let us not do that that's
not Hugh Jackman no no no you're bad if
you're good heart of Batman's character
part of what makes Batman Batman is this
physicality how tall you're tall is your
guy my guys six foot tall Donal Brian
he's a beast he's done movies like this
before an American assassin without
checked that death we see
playing a dance probably so that we see
how to plan a guy who's grizzled who can
fight who can throw down who can
actually be physically intimidating both
your guys's Oscar Isaac is tiny and
Zachary Quinto is like like you just
said beefed up it's like the guy is so
scrawny here and on top of that at least
I can see a little bit of charm I don't
see any sure was that great Quincy would
be a great like relax I could see as a
Quinn told Lex first of all that's a
good casting but not as bad first of all
I watched American assassin and I looked
at the screen said what a great Batman
and I was referring to my buddy Brian he
can't he's just not that good and his
movies prove it The Maze Runner no one
was from sitting in the reviews for
something like Maze Runner like look
this movie is garbage but Dylan O'Brien
really then why isn't Dylan O'Brien a
bigger name why isn't he booking these
bigger roles the ability to do his own
stunts unless you're Tom Cruise is kind
of it has nothing to do with being
Batman but here's what I will say
Zachary Quinto is too scrawny I mean you
could have said the same thing about
Christian Bale come on
building the physique is is I know it's
I say this somewhat tongue-in-cheek but
that's kind of the easy part of this you
can build the body sure the body's there
what you can't build is you can't you
can't take the charm of the actor you
can't take the mystique of the answer
Zachary Quinto absolutely mystique
you're talking you were saying earlier
about Batman being this guy this aloof
person who maybe doesn't quite know how
to fit in I mean the public persona but
look at how Spock is that Spock is the
ultimate detective of space that's
exactly what we already know that he can
deliver those lines he can deliver the
the detective part while also bringing
kind of the unhinged nosov Sylar but we
also know that he has the humanity well
that's why I think to me Zachary Quinto
is great casting for a Batman movie as
Red Hood
no I don't buy I don't see it
I still like my casting of Zachary
Quintos Lex I think that's a good idea I
think everything you said about Spock is
like perfect he's very stoic he's smart
he's intellectual but he's not charming
he's not likeable he's not a guy you
want to hang around with that Bruce has
I think he holds that entire three
movies together of the Maze Runner
movies I think everything is based on
him not just his action scenes but also
his charm his likability his ability to
lead because throughout those entire
three movies he's a leader throughout
those moves well my brothers I think he
went a little too young to me we're
veering on Gotham territory here because
the big thing about Bruce Wayne is that
he comes back at an age where he can be
like the man out and about and I however
old Dylan O'Brien is almost 30 however
he actually is he does read more like
and I think that's why he can still play
teenagers in young adult films which is
perfectly fine there's nothing wrong
with that but I wanted kind of a Batman
who basically was talking about before
the show started about movies that feel
like prequels to the actual movies and
I'm worried about the casting of Dylan
O'Brien will be like here's the Batman
movie are gonna get in Batman too but
here's here's another problem that I
think you brought up prequels with Oscar
Isaac I do think that if you were to put
Oscar Isaac side-by-side with Ben
Affleck's Batman it's very similar and I
think that DC I think their best move
right now is to not try to kind of make
it seem like oh yeah this was kind of
maybe the younger version of Ben Affleck
I think you just go a completely
different direction I'm not saying they
portray him as a younger Ben outweigh
the comparisons are gonna be there I
think the comparisons are gonna be there
for both because they're both four year
old middle aged men I think we've seen
this before we say no he looked at every
single Batman we've seen has been a
middle-aged guy
let's go younger let's go to a younger
Bruce Wayne let's actually pass the
torch to a new generation who can give a
new Batman franchise also this movie is
taking place in 2021 I mean it's not
like we're talking about next week that
this comes out sure this is for the
future or the Batman franchise this can
go on 10 years who better to do this
than a young and up-and-coming action
star like a Dylan O'Brien I just don't
trust Dylan O'Brien he has shown me
nothing so far that gives Holden
what's pili between Magda no no Brian
we'll find out in final thoughts perhaps
and let's start our final thoughts off
with camera and go for it I understand
what everybody's saying about the age
number on Oscar on Oscar Isaacs but what
I would say to that is that man is not a
man who looks like he's 40 Poe Dameron
is not struggling to run to his x-wing
by no means that's a very in shape man
I'd also to me it's not that idea to
finally have someone of color playing
Batman change it up this would be the
fifth or sixth cinematic iteration of
Batman give me something a little new
all right thank you camera we channeling
Elaine Seinfeld thank you sir hey I
think Dylan O'Brien has proven to people
throughout not just the Maze Runner
movies but every other movie he's have
been a part of that not only does he
bring that physicality that action star
quality that you want to see in a Batman
you want to see that physicality
regardless of what anyone says that's
what the general movie-going audience
wants to see I think that alone Brian
brings that but he also brings an amount
of youthfulness
and amount of charm and if you want to
see something different let's give it to
an actual young Batman when they say
young let's go young let's go with
someone who can bring a new franchise to
the future let's not just go with the
average 40 year old guys all over again
as we've seen from the past so many
years of Batman movies we see the same
thing over and over again let's give it
to a young person who can bring this
franchise to the future and that's why I
chose Dylan O'Brien Thank You ace Oscar
Isaacs is average tell me Internet Billy
biz I can Karen you said you want
something new I feel like I feel like
you're just you're making a lateral move
here with Oscar Isaacs except I don't
think he can pull off the darkness I
don't think I don't think Poe bad a man
can be as dark as you think that he can
I just don't feel like he's I don't
think he's got it I think you're just
basically you're kind of like it feels
like dollar-store Ben Affleck it feels
like you're just trying to find
something that kinda looks like it
squint maybe Ben Affleck but it's not I
think with Dylan O'Brien look I get
where you're come
from and I don't even think it's wrong
to say like let's go for an up-and-comer
but I think the problem is you put your
money on someone that is a proven track
record of not delivering I don't really
know who Dylan O'Brien is I don't really
care who Dylan O'Brien is I've heard
nothing about like oh man the all these
movies are hot garbage fires but Dylan
O'Brien sure looked like a star and that
happens with a lot of movies that aren't
great but they're good performances I
don't think that's your guy
Zachary Quinto is someone that's
unexpected and we've seen when you get
the unexpected casting sometimes with
comic book movies at first here just
like this makes no sense I don't get it
we got it with Michael Keaton but I
think Zachary Quinto would be one of
those ones where you see the picture six
months into filming and he's buffed up
and he's working out and you're like I
see it now I see I see the pathos I see
a little bit of the crazy there but I
also see a little bit of the humanity I
see where the story could be going I see
an actor who has proven that he can
carry a franchise I think Zachary Quinto
is somebody that when you think about it
more it makes sense time there you go
three different bat men one fact-checker
Dan Merle things yeah the first thing
there was many people many references to
Oscar Isaacs Oscar Isaac singular
singular although an army of Oscar
Isaacs I think would be delightful
people could dream oh yeah a lot of
great movies coming out of that Oscar
Isaac currently 39 years old
Zachary Quinto currently 41 years old
Zillah O'Brien currently 27 years old
for looking canonically Batman at one
time in Batman year one was stated as
being 25 years old when he started
becoming Batman however with the new 52
a lot of the old mythology has been
washed away but between 25 and 30 is you
generally considered the age around
which he became Batman height was
brought up Oscar Isaac is officially
these are official listings are
officially listed as five-foot-nine
Dylan O'Brien officially listed at 5
foot 10 and Zachary Quinto at 6 1 yeah
buddy
and age was brought up if we're looking
at cinematic Batman ages Ben Affleck was
the oldest he was about 43 years old
Michael Keaton in Adam West for both
around 38 Val Kilmer and George Clooney
were right around 36 and Christian Bale
was the youngest cinematic Batman he was
right around 31 when Batman Begins came
out
I'm surprised George Clooney was only 36
because George Clooney has been like he
went from like ER to just 50 forever bad
because Val Kilmer and George Clooney
were both Batman by 36 and I'm 36 I
failed that's the measuring stick maybe
be Kilmer to Batman who's Dan flick
stick the athletes thank you Dan so yeah
I thought there were solid arguments all
around if Cameron listed a lot of the
qualities the brooding the valiant
leader and even more brooding with Lou
and Davis and Billy I love that he
brought up like Spock is the ultimate
space detective I think we should have
that you know a Star Trek movie
mr. Spock space detective but at the end
of the day I mean I hate to hate on my
own middle-aged men but I thought ace
really started to paint a like an
exciting picture of a different Batman
that we have not seen before and like
like I didn't want I didn't want to like
your answer I went into this not
thinking the Maze Runner would be a good
Batman but at the end of the day I came
out thinking you know what that's the
Batman I want to see out of these three
so I'm going s Dan yeah I think Ace was
fighting from a position of strength
here because it is the young Batman and
he was correct that they did pick both
actors that were very near the age of
previous Batman that we've seen and I
felt like Billy was someone that went
hardest in on Dylan O'Brien but they
were all very subjective arguments it
was just like well I've never heard of
this guy
I don't know him and that's true but
that's not really a very strong argument
for why and cited the game I still an
old Brian so I'm also going with ace I
just felt like he was up against two
very Sammy answers and he had kind of a
fresher take on it I think that was the
powerful position and nothing that I
heard swayed me off of that so I'm gonna
go with ace right on ace you're taking
the point in that round Danielle what
the polls say another Batman etc all
right so at 49% we had zachary quinto at
32% Oscar Isaacs 17% for Dylan O'Brien
other names that were thrown around
someone threw out a Jason Doering which
deep cut I like it we also got Jon Hamm
and Adam driver John Baron thought
Drew's Elba Charlie Cox Will Arnett
which could be really interesting armie
hammer rami malek marshall ah Arlie and
then one that I've really liked on
Twitter David pockets 90 round one Jack
Houston has been tossed around for Bruce
Wayne / Batman and he's my pick he's
incredible as the smite sniper mob
enforcer and Boardwalk Empire and just
has the class about him he's a
phenomenal actor who deserves a bigger
audience I agree with all of those
things and I think that he would be able
to pull off the duality of a Bruce Wayne
Batman right on thank you for breaking
it down for us Danielle so going into
question number two it is ace one Billie
Cameron looking to get on the board here
we go
oh so sticking with something a Warner
Brothers er related the WB is developing
a Funko movie based on the famous vinyl
toy you guys know a Funko pops are you
probably got some sitting right next to
you as you watch movie fights umm what
director could make a Best Picture
contender or the just the best Funko
movie man that'd be crazy a Funko movies
a Best Picture
but we asked who'd make the best Funko
movie and we're gonna start with player
number two for question number two ace I
chose these two directors who everyone
laughed and everyone scoffed at the idea
when it was brought up before with the
lego movie
and that is Phil Lord and Chris Miller
these guys are two directors who have
proven time and time again through
animated features through comedies
through any type of movie everything
they touch has been gold the lego movie
was incredibly delightful they were able
to take a toy and make it an actual fun
movie that everyone can enjoy
they did it with Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs they brought so much joy in 21
and 22 Jump Street and they did it again
with spider-man into the spider verse
which is probably gonna win the Oscar
this year I say the best bet is Lord and
Miller because they have that proven
track record of making great animated
features Thank You ace delivers I think
with something like Funko pop your mind
immediately goes to what what is
something that kind of worked in that
sense and that's why I totally
understand your pick I even thought
about it myself but I wanted to go a
step further and think okay so what else
could work what could set Funko pop
aside different and I think someone who
could bring comedy because I think you
can't do something like this without
comedy but also bring some other aspects
to it outside of the box is none other
than Jordan Peele I think Jordan Peele
showed us not only can he do something
like get out which was disturbing but
funny and all these different genres
mixed together but tell it in a fresh
new way this is a voice that all of us
really want to hear right now I mean
just the trailer alone for this horror
movie that he's doing maybe if it was
another director we wouldn't even know
that us was a movie coming out but it's
Jordan peels new movie and already it
has a prestige behind it that a lot of
other movies don't have and I think you
hear that Jordan Peele is gonna do
Twilight Zone you hear he's going to do
these projects you immediately already
are like okay maybe I wasn't excited
before but if he's gonna do it I want to
see what Jordan Peele will do and I
think he could actually take a concept
like Funko pops and make it something
thanks Billy macaroni Cameron so I
wanted to go in a different direction
with something like this because
obviously the idea is to maybe make a
comedic animated style movie that's
totally fine there's nothing wrong with
that
I wanted to see if we can maybe switch
it up change it up a little bit I'm
going with guillermo del toro a man who
loves himself some collectibles who
loves himself some toys but always finds
the sadness and the beauty within all of
those things we've all been so the
targets or the hot topic or anything
like that where you see there's a bunch
of Funko's and there's the one character
that's consistently there there's 18 of
a character from stranger things or
anything like that what's that character
story it's Toy Story meets Funko meets
this lonely sadly toy toy trying to find
a home and I think the person who does
that story and because again the
question is about Best Picture winner
this guy won Best Picture Best Director
last year I think guillermo del toro
making the Funko pop movie you got a
chance
all right fight it out y'all so I think
with guillermo del toro to me i think
where he really shines is his
imagination and when he can control the
production design what these things look
like he can go big with these monsters
these fantasy his imagination is just so
rich yes and I feel like with something
like Funko pops he's gonna be a little
limited to what the Funko pops actually
are and I don't feel like a Funko movie
is the best use of Guillermo del Toro
and I think that's where he's gonna fall
now for Lord Miller I think again like I
said that was even my first thought
immediately but they've already done
that movie they've already taken their
stance and honestly I I don't know I
just don't with lord Miller you hear
these horror stories of what they were
gonna do with Han Solo and how it turned
out to be a big could have been it could
have been it but if we can't work with
these other filmmakers I'm just gonna I
don't know I think that they could I
think they could deliver another great
lego movie but I don't want another
great lego movie I have the lego movie
I'm tired of the Lego well now let's
just say Lord and Miller produced the
spider-verse they're not directed but
some rope they about to your response to
my response to the general de Toro being
creative and things like that I think
there's a great merchandising
opportunity if they let him create his
own Funko's and you can call it a go
Funko and he has his own line of toys
and they are made for
this movie they launched out of this
film and much like Toy Story like the
characters that Sid created what if this
movie was about those kinds of creations
these insane
weird-looking toys that no one wants to
buy and garam other targets to tell the
story of the sad toy who's just trying
to find a way out of a hot tub I think
part of it too we have to realize is
that what makes Funko pops so popular is
the IP it is that it's [ __ ] but buying
stuff that I already know and love who
can take these characters that we
already know and love they've been
rumored Deadpool Wonder Woman Darth
Vader who better than actual fans who
know these characters well if I want
someone to write Deadpool besides the
writers of Deadpool who better than Lord
and Miller they've already proven that
they have incredible comedy chops
they can bring heart and humor into
their movie with the lego movie with
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs and as
I said before Phil Lord wrote spider-man
into the spider is an incredible movie
that had both heart and humor they're
able to take properties that we already
know whether it's spider-man whether
it's Han Solo whether it's Batman as
Lego Batman in the lego movie all these
characters we know and love Lord and
Miller have proven that they can do that
in an oscar-worthy movie because like I
said before it's probably gonna win the
Oscar this year and it should have won
one the little game I like what I like
about Lord and Miller though is that
every new movie is a different
interesting show I think all of our
directors have different interesting
choices as their next movie I think if
it was announced Lord and Miller we're
doing Funko I would feel a degree of
like oh well there's two years we're not
gonna get a new interesting different
question the question is best contender
for best picture of an awesome and I
don't think I love fun different movie
it's the movie that you most think is
going to win an Oscar and I feel that it
should be Spielberg
keep saying Lord and Miller gonna
probably get one for spider-verse but
again that's not Lord and Miller proper
if you want to say Lord Miller couldn't
even get one actually about the case
because they would take Miller and the
writers Lord Miller couldn't even get
the oscar for lego movie and you're
saying this is the if they're just gonna
oh yeah I can do the lego movie let's do
have a pop well they didn't win for Lego
so there goes the chances I think
they're totally gonna win for spider-man
I think it's the clear front-runner I
think they shine for like is the
question about general Oscar because if
so we have no talk to David Ayer about
Suicide Squad just said no it says Best
Picture contenders who have proven they
can take IP stuff that all nerds like
and make it funny make it relatable and
have a lot of heart in humor I think if
we're gonna pick the directors that have
that the best in that case it is Lord
and Miller also it's animated movies who
what is Guillermo de Toro done is I mean
shape of water was an r-rated when I
produced on a produce book of life was
it called anitha I really don't feel
like no game a little Toro lights and
creating original characters original
stories original r-rated stuff not fun
animated movies that can be relatable
for poopy why we say the question was
not about fun animated the question was
about Best Picture content it's a relate
to is the best blade movie of the three
I agree with that but here's Jordan
Peele has given us one movie one movie
so far I mean as great as he is I love
Jordan people and get out was my
favorite movie that that year but it's
one movie and we and he wants to do how
do you know that that's not what his
take on Funko would be that's what my
question is I think Jordan Peele could
bring something I think this could be
and I don't want to pitch it as this is
the exact story but I think it could
have something akin to like a gremlins
where it's kind of like this horror
esque take it's this different take it's
something that we're not getting from
this this onslaught of Lego movies and I
think what Jordan Peele is proven and
yes he's had one movie one very
successful movie one oscar-nominated
movie but also let's not discredit that
this guy also had a couple seasons of
key and Peele behind him one of the
funniest sketch shows of all time the
guy knows
to write comedy he also knows how to
write kind of dark twisted things that
make you think and honestly when I think
of a funkopop Spencer said it the other
day I see these soulless weird wild
creatures Carl finds the don't like
Funko pops as someone who likes Funko
pops and collects Funko pops I'm gonna
say to you that I like the properties I
like the IP I like the characters that I
like again I'm not I'm not gonna show
you the only twisted I don't want to see
a creepy creepy monsters not projecting
my my own view of what I think this
movie should be but what I'm saying is
Jordan Peele can handle anything you
throw at him if you want fun and cute
and and super funny on the level of like
a 21 Jump Street or lego movie
we know that key is sorry that Jordan
Peele is up for the task if you want to
take it a little bit darker and make it
stand out and unique we also know that
Jordan peels up to the task I don't
think that Guillermo del Toro I think he
can do the big imagination stuff I don't
think that if you wanted it to be fun
and funny I don't think he's going to
final thoughts won't start with ace give
us your final thoughts my final thoughts
are this question was we can make the
Best Picture contender Lord and Miller
have proven not just by writing
spider-man into despite of hers but my
producing spider-man into despite a
verse and finding the talent to create
an incredible animated movie that's
probably going to win the Oscar this
year they've proven it with Cloudy with
a Chance of Meatballs making a
remarkable fun animated film and they've
proven it with the lego movie these guys
are able to handle heart and humor so
well and what makes the Funko pops what
everyone likes about them is the IP it's
stories that you can relate to who
better to take characters like Deadpool
characters like Darth Vader characters
like Wonder Woman and make him fun
charming relatable funny something that
kids can enjoy because they say hey look
that's Deadpool hey look that's Wonder
Woman I like those characters then Lord
and Miller out of outside of Disney the
animated movies that have stood out the
most are created by Lord and Miller
these guys are giants at creating
fantastic animated features and that's
why they're my choice
Thank You ace Billy I think that if Lord
and Miller were to take over the
funkopop the way that you just described
it in your final closing arguments
you're just getting another reheated
version of the lego movie and the lego
movie didn't win Best Animated Picture
I think that it's probably it was
groundbreaking for what it was but I
think if they take their approach and
just do it to a different packaging
you know just moving it from Lego toys
to Funko toys they're just doing the
same thing and I think it's gonna grow
tired on people I mean the reviews for
lego movie 2 are already coming up we
were like okay I get it I think with
Guillermo del Toro whenever he tried to
really dig into IP yeah the fans really
liked it but if we're talking about Best
Picture stuff it wasn't blade it wasn't
Hellboy that got him on the map it was
when he was able to let go with his full
imagination with shape of water and I
just don't think that someone like mo
del Toro is gonna deliver a satisfying
Funko pop movie and I think what you
want with this Funko pop movie is
someone that understands the potential
humor there that understands how you
could use that IP someone that
understands how this could be something
original and right now one of the most
original filmmakers that we have is
Jordan Peele he elevates everything that
he has attached to Twilight Zone how
many reboots have there been were we
just like okay I guess they're doing
that again but the minute they said
Jordan peels Twilight Zone we all took
notice I think you attached to her and
Peele to this you immediately know that
you're going to get something fresh
something out of the box and I think
that could take a concept like Funko
pops which we all rolled our eyes at and
10 years from now we could be like man
you remember that awesome Funko pop
movie we'll see about that Cameron so
the question was about Best Picture now
let's take shape of water out of the
equation you also have Pan's Labyrinth
and you also have Devil's Backbone and
we're talking about things respecting
the things that fans are into he did do
play too he had Hellboy he had Hellboy
to pet Pacific Rim was its own thing but
it was also playing on the fandom of
giant kaiju creatures and robots I think
a person who can take a pick a concept
an idea and making sure it's both
respectful to the fans but also
something that's moving and something
the Academy would be into and meld those
two things together
Guillermo del Toro the Lord and Miller
movie the minute it's pitched I see it
in my head I know exactly what that
movie is I don't know what the Jordan
Peele movie is that's certainly
interesting but nothing I have seen so
far has shown me he is a geek friendly
for lack of a better term I think the
best option of these three options who's
going to give you a Best Picture and
make fans happy is gamal del Toro BAM
there's the end of that round Dan what
please a favor of switch back and go
ahead and give us your thoughts on the
question as well factually yes garand
also did produce the book of life which
was animated film I should spider-man
into the spider-verse win the Academy
Award for Best Animated Feature Lord and
Miller will receive an Oscar as
producers of the film along with the
directors and there is actually of the
three directors there is a Guillermo del
Toro Funko pop the question was which of
these directors has a Funko pop and
Cameron won however I do feel like of
the three his was the one that I was
able to eliminate I just felt like that
he was argued against very strongly and
everyone actually argued that their
choice is really really well in this
round but Guillermo was when I had to
get rid of first and sort of set aside
so they came between ace and Billie for
me and I think that that much like flash
around in the case was kind of arguing
for a position of power but both Cameron
abilities sort of chipped away at him
and I think Billy had a very strong
closing argument for Jordan Peele the
fact that he could produce something
that we look back on that could be
really memorable really special I think
that he swatted back against people
saying that he could not deliver
something of that caliber that he has
the experience writing comedy not just
get out so my vote in this round goes to
Billy thank you Dan
one for Billy yeah I saw it a little bit
differently I agree that Ace was arguing
from a position of power here because
it's like oh yeah it's a no-brainer make
it that then it's like oh yeah I thought
he got knocked down that do we want it
that exact like it wouldn't be obviously
the exact same thing but started to feel
a little too
a me and just the taste of my mouth got
say me I don't know what that means but
you know what I mean and so came down to
Billy and Cameron for me and I actually
I thought Cameron hit these like these
specific feelings of the story I really
love like the lonely funk oh that hasn't
been that wasn't sold the logo Funko
thing it just started like and then I
pictured Garrow lending some soul the
kind that he does and he has dealt with
popular IPS before so yeah by a little
bit I thought Billy made a good argument
for Jordan Peele but Cameron spoke to me
the most I have to go with Cameron so
let's go to Danielle alright with the
people's vote we have 37% for Jordan
Peele 36% for board and Miller in
guillermo del toro with 25% that's Billy
you take the point my friend Danielle
any other uh yeah thoughts mentioned we
had some good someone recommended um Rob
McElhenney which I think isn't I don't
know he's ever done an animation but
that could be interesting
Edgar Wright Roberts a mess Robert is a
met kiss Joe Dante who also did small
soldiers and the burbs and the bird and
gremlins and someone do Baca depends on
Twitter says David Cronenberg Nolan Dean
27 on Twitter says this is a weird take
but the thing about all Funko's is the
simple design with the symmetrical
facial expressions and the high detail
around it and that when at its best is
colorful and fun to look at I'm going
with Wes Anderson for the fun kind of an
interesting at the box interesting hmm
cool so after two questions it's Billy
one ace one Cameron loves me well Mogens
all right now
an argument there so its weight but
you're looking to tie it up and get on
the board here with question number
three
Aquaman it's now the highest-grossing DC
superhero movie of all time
what DC character should team up with
Aquaman a la Tony Stark and spider-man
for an Aquaman bump so who should team
up with Aquaman what DC superhero that's
a fun one uh and let's start off with
player number three mr. Billy biz sure
do you want me to give my mini pitch for
what I think this movie would be uh or
just say the name of the character and
go from there you know what um watch it
let's let's do it that way let everybody
say the name of your character and then
yeah sure um so I'm gonna go with I
think dick Grayson's Nightwing would
benefit the most from having a little a
little Justice League Aquaman rub nice
dick Grayson's Nightwing we saw a
picture of him right there cool around
to Cameron I'm going with Blue Beetle
specifically the current iteration of
Blue Beetle Jaime Reyes Jaime Reyes
incarnation of Blue Beetle and then ace
are we just saying the character yeah
[Laughter]
I'm going with my homie the martian
manhunter john jones cool martian
manhunter okay
let's fight it out quick elevator pitch
of why I think um so I think that the
reason why Tony Stark was used
effectively in spider-man homecoming is
not because he aided in the origin story
of Peter Parker it's because he aided to
the story that was being told about
Peter Parker so I think for me with
Nightwing I don't really you know I what
I see with Nightwing is a story about
dick racing he's now left Batman and I
think you have a hero who doesn't really
know am i hero because I had Bruce
Wayne's money and my hero because I was
part of the bat family I don't know what
it means to be here on my own I don't
know am I supposed to be like dark and
mean like Batman and my lighter I don't
know who I am
and I think that he tackles a case that
has to do with you know where he needs
he needs a little help and I think he
goes to Aquaman as more of a mentor like
hey you know maybe it's like poison
poisoning the water or something but I
think he goes documen like hey I need
your help in Aquaman he's like you have
an army you have your big Trident that's
what gives you your power I need your
power I need your help with this he's
like no you need to figure this one out
on your own
and I think I think it turns out that
Aquaman is the one that's like hey Bruce
told me to kind of keep an eye on you
and he's the one that's telling Aquaman
like you know that's kind of this in
this like telephone game of how Batman's
doing and everything and I think he
explains - Nightwing like look I was
just a guy I didn't want anything to do
with this but I chose to do the right
thing it doesn't matter if I had my
Trident it doesn't matter if you have
all of Bruce's tech your hero just being
who you are
like I'm not a king because of this
trident and I think at the end of the
movie that's kind of like your little
Easter eggs thing is like you see Arthur
at the end telling Batman like I think
he's gonna be okay I think you taught
him well and I think that's how you use
Aquaman you don't use him as a you know
a tag-team partner I think you use him
as kind of a vessel for for an ark for
dick it's something I really liked about
Aquaman was I mean Aquaman is a billion
dollar movie and regardless and when
people thought about I personally loved
the movie I thought it was a lot of fun
and and and that's what I want to see in
an Aquaman movie I want to see who can
bring a different dynamic with Aquaman
and I think who better personality wise
then the Martian Manhunter someone who's
known for being very stoic for being
very humorless almost like an oddball
couple to this crazy over-the-top Jason
Momoa Aquaman I think that dynamic that
oddball that Odd Couple dynamic between
the two would be the best part of this
movie not just that but something that I
really enjoyed a Baughman and I think
everyone can take away from it was the
incredible visual visual effects in fact
I think it was snubbed for the Oscar
visual effects because I think it looked
incredible and and what better to take
the power dynamics of a Martian
Manhunter someone who can shape-shift
someone who can do telepathy I want to
see what James Wan can do with the power
set visually with the Martian Manhunter
so personality wise I think they create
an incredible dynamic and power wise I
think we can see some crazy monster
battles with the Martian Manhunter
shape-shifting into giant sea creatures
and joining in with Aquaman I think
that's the kind of fun that we want to
see as a follow-up to a billion dollar
movie I don't I don't think we should
scale it back I think we should just
give him more into them interesting um
so for me what I liked about Tony Stark
was in that spider-man movie was that it
wasn't Tony's movie there was concern
when that was coming out like well this
just make Tony's movie featuring
spider-man and I would like to take a
similar approach where this is the Blue
Beetle movie because it's about the
Aquaman bump it's about hey featuring
this character
here's another character everyone knows
who spider-man is but at the very least
here's a character who you're not super
familiar with but this this other bigger
dude is in this so the story about Jaime
Reyes is he gets the Blue Beetle scarab
and it's not necessarily by choice he's
kind of this powers thrusted upon him
and there's two different origins now
there was the pre 52 and post with you -
whether it's magic or alien all that
stuff that's all complicated we don't
need to get into that in the movie but
the fact of the matter is he now has
this power set he lives in Texas which
is pretty far away from Samoa
which I think would make this fun it's a
fish out of water story you're not quite
doing the Thor thing but the fact of the
my idea is Aquaman is sent to recruit
Blue Beetle and throughout the whole
thing blue beetles like I don't anything
to do with this I didn't want these
powers this is not something I wanted I
just want to go to high school and I
think you can have some fun comedic
moments it's almost like alchemy just
continues to follow Blue Beetle around
trying to recruit him it's almost like
ghosts if everyone could see Patrick
Swayze it Whoopi Goldberg she's like
leave me alone
and finally the black beetle who's blue
beetles nemesis shows up and tries
destroying the small Texas town and
that's where you do get the fun action
scenes of Aquaman helping Blue Beetle
and trying to be like who's them there's
awesome braum who feels like no no I
don't want a part of this you don't
wanna be that too long and eventually
you do have to have that point of this
is what you need to be doing it's the
responsible thing to do Blue Beetle does
come into his own it gives us that
teenage character and throughout the
whole movie peppering in this like we're
recruiting you we're recruiting you you
think it's gonna be the Justice League
at the very end blue beetles ready to be
Blue Beetle and says I'm ready to join
Justice League and go and Aquaman goes
you're a little too young for that man
cut to Seattle backdoor Teen Titans
movie so here's what I had to say about
this and this is why I want to say like
I think what made Tony Stark's
appearance and spider-man homecoming
work so well is that we did already know
House Peter Parker with spider-man and I
know you glossed over very fast like how
it's very confusing but it's like for
most people they don't know who Blue
Beetle is no and there's a there's a
simplification way you you they just
have to push on it is it magic or the
alien I know but I think that either way
you go that's an interesting story and I
feel like to take away from the origin
story of one of the few Latino
characters I know there's like no
hunters and characters as far as
superheroes go and Blue Beetle is one of
the few characters that's actually a
Latino character are we really gonna
make him like a sidekick to Aquaman oh
no not at all no that's that's why
let's give Blue Beetle his own movie III
love Blue Beetle I love the character
Jaime Reyes and bustled Texas next round
he's a great character at that that
should be its own movie I I think what
makes Aquaman so Aquaman is a billion
dollar movie people love it
we want to see an addition to Aquaman we
want to see Aquaman team up with someone
that
take away his shine that's why I think a
martian manhunter can bring in that
spectacle and that humor I'd love the
dynamic of a Martian Manhunter with
humor Maya Sherwood Nightwing - is that
that doesn't feel like it matches up
world wise I just don't see how
Nightwing is gonna fit with anything
having to do with Atlantis number one
and number two as far as Batman goes I
think that's gonna be confusing for
audiences like who's Nightwing is this -
which Batman is he referring to is it
this Batman is it the other Batman I'm
sure way too confusing for audience I
also think that we're moving into a
period of DC where we can be a little
bit more fast and loose like we don't
have to be like okay well then if it's
this it's got to be this continuity but
I also think you keep talking about the
visual spectacle and everything yeah I
think Martian Manhunter already has that
and I think that when when you add
Aquaman to mine you can open up the
world a little bit it's not just I think
that's an important thing for verdict to
realize like this world is so much
bigger than just your little pocket of
the city but I think with Martian
Manhunter I think and I love Martian
Manhunter
I think that's a great character and I
think he's being used properly in
something like Supergirl where he is
more of the mentor role I don't think
you need to add an Aquaman to anything
Martian Manhunter to up the wow factor
Marshall Manhunters he's got it already
you don't need the Aquaman bump there I
think for yours yeah I'm not trying to
gloss over the movie my ideas you spend
most of the time with Jaime and his
family and the small tech start getting
that spider-man movie ten minutes yeah
not a ton of screen that's a character
that we know and so is spider-man a
character that we know versus Jaime
Reyes Jaime Reyes deserves his own movie
he doesn't need to be paired up with a
character that we already know with
Aquaman hooah billions like a billion
dollar movie so many people from around
the world know Aquaman that a point of a
job the point the point of a bump is to
hey this person is in here so now you're
definitely gonna go see this other
person's movies these might not have
heard us use the Rose amar
not going to most likely not have like
Superman or Wonder Woman showing up in
Shazam because we need to invest in that
character first we need to learn about
that character before we can start
giving them the bump
we already got a little bit of Peter
Parker but in civil war before we even
got to his own movie and like I said
with that just had the benefit of
everybody knows that story we don't need
to do it all over again my question
would be does everyone to truly beyond
this room and the internet uh-huh does
everyone truly know Nightwing
III think like or are you bogging down
the first twenty minutes of your movie
here's I would say everyone knows who
dick grayson is yes and i think the
story of Dick Grayson being a part of
the bat family and leaving that that's a
story that okay even if I don't know who
Nightwing is and I don't know his
history I understand he was Robin I
understand now he's trying to do his own
thing
Billy roll this into your final shot I
think that's an easily relatable thing
for the audience to pick up on I think
also that Aquaman is going to work best
when it can open up the world and be
pushed that character forward in their
story I think this idea that Aquaman
having been a reluctant hero a little
bit of himself and going after the
Trident and what does it mean to be a
hero what does it mean to have this
power I think he could be the one that
really imparts that lesson in dick of
hey like look you don't have to be mean
like Batman you don't have to have his
tech you do you because the hero is
inside of you I think that's a good
message I think that's something that
Aquaman you can bring in a little bit of
the Atlantis spectacle to open it up
whereas Martian Manhunter like I said I
see him as more of a mentor for somebody
else
I see his movie being again another
origin story where we need to kind of
figure out what happened to him and his
family and I think the spectacle is
already there I don't think adding
Aquaman is going to benefit that movie
that much with yours I think it's just
it's just not time yet the world needs
to hear Jaime Reyes a story first and
that story is compelling enough that it
shouldn't have any interference from any
other DC comic character Thank You Billy
around the horn to Cameron to me I think
what the reason I wanted to include
Aquaman
the Jaime Reyes is origin story and
again more ISM recruiting more is a come
along with me it's the mirror version of
say something like Unforgiven where the
person goes to the person's house and
goes you need to come on this journey
but that movies not about the blonde kid
from Unforgiven it's about Clint
Eastwood the movie would still be about
Jaime it's about having a bump not about
being a co-star I think my movies also
just it's simpler that a kid in Texas
gets powers is a simple story I think
both these movies you have to go into a
20 minute plot diatribe about the white
Martians and the green Martians and fire
and all this other stuff and now the
movie starts and was Dick Grayson he was
Robin's not this Robin now he's
Nightwing this and now the movie can
start I feel you can open my movie small
Texas town and I think immediately
people would go there's a superhero
movie and it's interesting and different
and you are learning the story of Jaime
his family the small Texas town and
Aquaman's just a fun character that pops
in and out he's not the main character
thanks Cameron ace I think Aquaman
obviously has proven to people that it's
an incredibly popular movie James Wan
delivered a billion dollar movie it's
the biggest DC movie we've seen so far I
mean this is the kind of stuff that has
international appeal that has global
appeal people in China love this movie
what people loved about it was the heart
the humor and the visual spectacle
Aquaman brought so much charm brought so
much fun and I think someone like a
Martian Manhunter can deliver that not
just the crazy visual spectacle that
people all around the world can enjoy
but also the humor the stoic nasai think
the Martian Manhunter is best used as a
supporting character versus these two
characters can't have their own movies
and need more explanation also Atlantis
Atlantis is a character in Aquaman and I
don't know how a Nightwing fits into
Atlantis and I don't know how a Jaime
Reyes fits into Atlantis I can see a
Martian Manhunter fitting into Atlantis
with his power dynamic with his
background and with the story that can
involve both of them as far as Martian
Manhunter giving more screen time to
Aquaman and giving more interactions
with humorous effect and that dynamic
between a crazy over-the-top Jason Momoa
now king of Atlantis leading his army
against an alien invasion that the
and Manhunter has come down to Atlantis
to face off with him something like that
that can that can bring in so many fans
that Aquaman can enjoy and not a side
character as in other movies
ring-a-ding-ding that's time for round
three dan where are we at with facts I
mean the pictures are all pretty much
just off the top of their head there was
one question of how much screen time
Iron Man had and spider-man huh yes sir
the estimates are about eight minutes No
about eight minutes of screen time and
reportedly a revenue to rubber dated you
took home about 10 mil no that's more
than a Wow
that's over a Milliman 'it not a bad
going rate not bad there you go that's
all yeah man actually I can't get over
that number I am at dumbfounded by that
yeah thank you Dan
so uh these were all great pitches I
really liked the the what you got what
everybody painted here yeah I thought
there was interesting and incorporation
here and I thought your you took us on a
journey I think you know Martian
Manhunter I really love just the idea of
the differing personalities I like you
involving uh more of the Justice League
in there Billy just like with the
Aquaman checking in a Batman at the end
and Cameron I feel like you know they
got some dings on you with saying that
that they want the Blue Beetle story but
I thought you countered well with the
Tony Stark argument just being that and
that is part of the question here and I
don't know if I'm being too literal but
that really started to resonate with me
because it felt like we were gonna get a
you know Jaime's full story here and
Aquaman would be a side dish in that
story and help him into the greater
superhero universe but we'd still tell
that character's story so that one
started other that I felt like so he
felt like you carried that attack and
otherwise I felt like you came out of it
pretty clean with the most interesting
story in my book and that's the one I
wanted to see most so I'm going with
Cameron and Blue Beetle dan a little bit
differently and everybody had a good
hold on their story and and I thought
that everyone pitched really well so I
just was kind of putting myself in the
position of the studio executive
listening to it
and for me the one that tracked the best
was aces just in the sense of like even
though I agree Cameron fought back a lot
of the negatives against his story very
well like just as a viewer I'm still
like but but how does Aquaman really fit
here and I thought that ace really
cracked the code of like yes Aquaman is
in the movie but how does he fit in the
movie and I thought to the Martian
Manhunter angle with the aliens that
bringing in Atlantis that was the best
fusion of the two characters that I
heard and so I'm going with ace alright
Danielle it comes down to you okay so
the poll right now is at 36% for
Nightwing 33% for Blue Beetle and 29%
for the Martian Manhunter alright so
that means that you will chime in with
your own opinion to decide the question
okay yeah I agree they were all really
good arguments I I hmm
I'm gonna go with ace I thought that ace
had a really solid argument still great
and were there any other so ace you get
the point on that one Danielle were
there any other mentions
and on Twitter or what-have-you for
potential choices oh yeah a lot of
people said the flash we got two types
of green lantern either Guy Gardner or
Jon Stewart both wildly different movies
a lot of Swamp Thing Shazam just a lot
of Nightwing first just a lot of just a
lot of Nightwing first and then this one
which will never happen but I just like
that it was brought up road Raider 3
said all right stay with me here Aquaman
takes care of the sea but his teammate
needs to be the master of the land or
Beale and Danny the street make it
happen
maybe the street is a character from
Doom Patrol he is actually a street and
just like you'll be walking down the
street and then all of a sudden you'll
realize you're on Danny and he
communicates using like shop signs and
and you know Road markers and things
like oh that's super fun it's super fun
and incredibly charming and I just
right on Thank You Danielle
so the speed round is set it's going to
be ace versus Billy Cameron you thought
you fought valiantly but you will be on
the sidelines for this one but maybe
I'll come to you for an opinion etc
gentlemen are you ready to throw down
let's do this okay speed round works
dust Lea I'll throw out the question and
then just shout out your answer first of
all here you'll have the chance to
elaborate on your question first
it'll be 20 seconds 20 seconds then back
around for 10 second rebuttal 10 second
rebuttal right now the score stands two
for Ace one for Billy first player to
four points wins here we go
question 1 - the speed around after
James Gunn who's next
MC who's the next M sorry I'm gonna
start that one all over I hope everyone
stays employed after James Gunn who's
the next MC u filmmaker who should take
on a DC property so read it one more
time son after James Gunn who's the next
MC u filmmaker who should take on a DC
property Tycho YTD Ryan Coogler
Ryan Coogler Taika Waititi we heard Tyco
first 20 seconds begin for ace as soon
as you speak the tech of ITV brought us
one of the most charming likeable fun
fast-paced Marvel movies and that his
store Ragnarok he brought Thor back from
the dead right when we thought Thor was
just gonna be a boring character I can
see him doing an amazing Booster Gold
movie that people have been wanting to
see he brings that heart he brings that
humour so many things that can be coming
at you at the screen so quickly Tyco YTD
can bring that and he brings his own
charm I think one of the strengths that
DC has right now especially with Aquaman
is building worlds that we haven't seen
before and that's exactly what Ryan
Coogler brings to the table with Black
Panther he built Wakanda this world that
we had never seen before he has this way
of telling stories that we really
connect with his characters with this
with Creed I think you take that kind of
gravitas and this imagined I know
exactly what Taika Waititi can bring for
a Booster Gold movie I'm not sure what
Ryan Coogler can bring and I've already
seen it with his humor and I think the
humor is the best part that could be
seen in a DC movie right now we want to
see humor done right I think if you give
Ryan Coogler or something like oh wow
with Green Lantern and you turn that cop
space cop thing into a real how this
would work and the world building of oh
I think he could actually make it
something people want to see and people
relate to oh good stuff you guys let's
start with Danielle Radford Oh can you
just for me can you repeat the the way
the question portion was phrased
absolutely after James Gunn who's the
next MCU filmmaker who should take on a
DC property this both of these were
incredibly compelling I have to say that
right now I want to see both of these
movies before me I think that the Ryan
Coogler argument was stronger he really
got into the world building telling the
story connecting characters he made me
see
oh and how that would work but man would
I ever want to see attack a watching
Booster Gold movie but yeah you are
going with yeah I'm going with regular
yeah such one for Billy yeah ace had me
but then Billy that that ten-second
rebuttal you won me over as well so I am
going Billy as I just threw my that's
excited there's another pen right here
do that all the time
okay it's so exciting pens are flying
question number two the speed round we
are tied at two-two
Pete Davidson formerly of our inner
Grundy will star in a comedy based on
his life for Judd Apatow what SNL cast
member
pastor present deserves a biopic ahead
of Pete Davidson Keenan sorry Kenan
Kenan yes Kenan Thompson yep Will
Ferrell alright we have Kenan Thompson
we have Will Ferrell Billy you spoke
first 20 seconds again when you speak
now I think what makes King and so
interesting is that he's been in this
business for so long I want to see how
this kid who is when other child actors
have fallen he's managed to stay
relevant his entire career I also think
that there's maybe some drama between
him and Kel and SNL I want to see all
that on screen I want to see the Kenan
and Kel drama I think he's a dude that I
want to know more about because he's
clearly still in the zeitgeist all these
years later
Will Ferrell is one of the most popular
SNL cast members that we've had over the
years and it's because of his crazy
insane humor that people have catered to
so much over the past few years he has
so many movies that people enjoy like
stepbrothers and anchorman and these are
the types of stories that I want to hear
about him coming up in New York being a
cast member of SNL getting involved with
the politics with the post and Bush
impersonation you name great Will
Ferrell movies and I want to see Will
Ferrell in a funny movie not a movie
about how well Ferrell is funny yeah I
get it but Kenan Thompson this is a
story about how is he able to succeed as
a child star actor all the way through
his career when a lot of others can
I think well farewell is not only a
bigger name but he's a name that more
people want to learn about he's a name
that people can see a movie about him
everyone can recognize the character of
Will Ferrell we can see him throughout
his college years we can see him coming
up in the Hollywood business going from
New York to LA time alright Dan Moreau
weep for Charles Rockets anyone before
mm I'm sorry I thought the question was
current SNL member that was it no it was
what SNL cast member past or present
well Dan I am going to stick though I
think of the two movies pitched I think
the Billy pitched a more compelling
storyline the the ability to stay with
it in the hardscrabble business of show
and any anything Kenan & Kel beef I'm on
board with to see that beef in the good
burger
all right thanks Dan
Danielle um I I gotta agree they were
both good there were both compelling
arguments but that I want to see Will
Ferrell in a funny movie not a movie
about why Will Ferrell was funny was
just such a knock out line you know also
yeah I want to see Kenan & Kel I want to
see Bri you know bring me some all of
that yeah three cement all that drama
right on okay so Billy you just vaulted
in ness heard the question I will still
help us to dumb I am you know
yeah hey oh good point but when they say
that just point to the scoreboard you're
all ready to read it - you got the point
there - question three question three
we've named a lot of SNL okay question
three of the speed round but I
appreciate the deep thoughts mm-hmm
The Rock will apparently not appear in
Fast and Furious nine what actor would
you cast to fill the void in the
ensemble ja Rule fire choice buildings
that's why FY Ace ah
I was gonna say some what about it I
think he's already in the first
franchise are gonna be in the fest
franchise I was gonna say interest elbow
but I think he's already coming out uh
he's gonna be in the Hobson Shaw yeah
so someone else rehearsal AVI okay we
have ja Rule we have rehearsal uh I'll
leave you broker follow me on this okay
22nd Billy when you speak this all be
worth it if I don't get this point by
the way look John Bull has already been
part of this franchise he's the only guy
that never came back I think what the
rocks not there you don't need so much
something in the movie you need to buzz
around the movie that's what fast eight
was missing so I think ja rule reprising
his character everyone's like wait a
second ja Rule he's gonna be the villain
right I want to see John role in this
movie he's already got the key behind
him we're already talking about it iron
that's the name of a song I think the
biggest takeaway that people have from
the fire festival besides billion is ja
rule being a monster he was evil he's
horrible I don't want to see him in a
movie I want to see an actor like my
Hershel oddly who brings gravitas who
brings strength who brings Auster
pedigree into an over-the-top action
franchise like a fast and furious movie
I think where Hershel ah can bring charm
can bring joy he can be a great villain
that's the kind of person I want to see
in a movie
Oscar Chung prestige we got we got the
Helen Mirren we got the the bad guy from
the last one they were all boring give
me someone with the rah-rah charisma
like the rock get me someone who's gonna
get people talking about this movie
give me Joe I think Joe is proving that
not only he's not a great actor he's not
a great person he's not a great human
being I don't want to see that in a
movie I want to see someone who brings
so much joy into being a villain someone
who brings us
Oscar pedigree someone like Murtagh oh
okay
man yeah I gotta give it to Billy for
the funniest answer but for the best
answer I gotta go with Raja strap
hey ace has it for me Danielle okay it's
one one
cuz she does have a magnesia scar docu
berries watch them all right after this
they're so good that's a song song it's
just crazy
Dan comes down to you on this the
question was
oh and by the way this is game point I
said that earlier it is game point for
Billy who should fill the void and the
cast not who's the best person and Billy
pitched a hell of a compelling reason
that people would be talking about this
movie would be wondering what he's doing
back is he a villain he's the only one
that never came back yeah buddy I feel
so bad for the people to get ripped off
but I got a vote for you just lost me
well played good sir you know what you
you staged a furious comeback and I
dedicate this one to you and GRA that
one's for you sitting on the couch sick
right now represent a new body nice
Billy uh thank you for shouting out ed
ed feel better
get well soon any other idea of anything
else you want to shout out or I just
want to shout out these gents I heard
some of the most compelling closing
arguments two of the nicest competitors
I had a great time so I don't want to
take any time on me I want you guys to
do you yeah but I'll second that they
did not make these choices easy on any
of us so uh yeah but Billy Congrats well
played brother ace nicely done you
thought like just kick ass arguments all
the way through um yeah how does it feel
to lose to someone who defies Vermillion
okay alleged is not an actor one but I
guess it doesn't matter yeah half the
cast of the faster actors really yeah
you can find me on Twitter ad squad
leader race and check out my new YouTube
channel it's called first cut that's
where our podcasts the meaning of is
going up now
my buddy RB 3 and I have director
discussion so we talk about our favorite
director that week and kind of go into
their filmography it's great if you're a
movie fan if you're a movie lover go
check it out give us some love on first
cut very cool
ace well played today thanks for being
here brother it's been Cameron great
answers all around sounding zero please
go ahead and shout out some stuff yeah
you can find me on twitter becomes less
drastic alien I have a show over at
hyper RPG on Tuesday nights that's a
twitch TV / riper RPG and also go check
out my photo Instagram its cameras photo
you got I got taking photos of people
who work in here you're JD's dog you're
great you're you're quite the shutterbug
and takes your great pics so yeah I
second that what what's the instrument
on I cam rice photo awesome thanks
brother thank you um Dan Moreau thank
you for all it down the facts
always reassuring feeling to have your
nimble fingers on the fact-check I do my
back yes any thoughts or any shout out
to anything no just uh thanks for
watching yeah yeah this is fun it's a
fun show how I do it and absolutely um
Daniel Radford I love just your laughs
it brings joy so just thank you for
being an awesome person please go ahead
and shout out or whatever
Instagram underscore Radford if you like
wrestling I have a wrestling podcast on
the max fun network called tights and
fights that comes out every Thursday
follow me for I guess my new podcast
I love ja Rule where am I generally is
that
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you talk about scary movie 3 I want to
thank you for watching you can hit me up
on Twitter and Instagram at Hal Rudnick
and I wanna once again say thanks for
watching
hashtag Al nation Percival's in the
house
hoot hoot and thank you everybody Thank
You Billy biz double duty fightin and
producing Thank You jte in the booth and
we'll see you next time bye bye
[Music]
you